Welcome back to human emotion.
So we've talked a lot about emotions and infancy and adolescence,
but what about the other part of the continuum in our lifespan?
What happens to emotions as we age and girls are like this man here in the
picture or this group of friends.
Do we grow into happier,
older people or more miserably for Lauren and depressed people as we reach the
very end of our life?
So here's a quote that I really liked when we think about aging and think about
the way that we respond to it emotionally.
So rabbi Joshua Liebman said,
I often feel that death is not the enemy of life,
but it's friend.
For it is the knowledge that our years are limited,
which makes them so precious.
So today we're going to conclude with our third series on emotion development by
looking at aging and now seeing ourselves is older,
really happier,
or can you be older and happier?
And we'll do this going through the following road map.
We'll start with one of the most pivotal theories in this area referred to as
the socioemotional selectivity theory.
Then we'll follow with some empirical evidence on emotion related changes in
aging.
And then we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's start first with one of the most groundbreaking theories that's
informed how we think about the development of our emotional self and identity
as we age,
the socioemotional selectivity theory or s s t theory.
So this is a theory that was put forth,
um,
predominantly by doctor Laura Carstensen from Stanford University along with
colleagues,
Derek,
exactly what's,
and Susan Charles.
So nothing is more familiar and scary than human aging.
They would argue yet exactly how does the perception of time passing as humans
and the relationship to our really time limited existence on this planet
influence our emotions.
So Carson's and and colleagues argue that the approach of endings,
including our life is associated with the heightened emphasis on feelings and
emotion states.
So they would argue that we really ought to take time seriously.
And in particular in her theory,
the SST theory,
she said that humans are uniquely able to monitor time,
both consciously and subconsciously.
She says that we set,
these are emotional goals within these temporal context.
We're always thinking about how we want to feel and how we should feel with an
idea of what timeframe we're in.
So when we think of aging and older adults,
she's found that older adults actually become more selective about social
networks.
So they spend more time with individuals with whom they have rewarding
relationships.
They also spend more time pursuing emotional satisfaction.
So as we near the end of our lives,
our emotional gauche goals shift to become more selective socially.
And we try to spend our time more preferentially on things that are going to
bring meaning and satisfaction.
And so you can think of emotional goals along two different kinds of categories.
One is perhaps focusing on the presence.
So living in the moment,
knowing what's important,
investing in sure things,
deepening your relationships and really trying to save her life.
This is contrast it with a different kind of tomorrow focus,
which is more about preparing for the future,
expanding your horizons,
Acquiring College,
meeting New People,
and taking challenges.
So do we focus more on the present as we age or do we focus more on preparing
for the future?
Well,
Carson's and in colleagues would actually argue that as we age,
it's indeed associated with more of a focus on the present right.
And activities that are unpleasant or often not compelling to spend your time
on,
um,
when,
when you're nearing the end of your lifespan and interest in novel information
because it's so closely intertwined with future needs becomes reduced.
And instead when endings are primed,
people focus on the present over the future.
This leads indeed Ben to different values,
people place on emotion as well as life more generally.
So how would this change the kinds of emotions that were going to experience as
we age?
And we can be become more focused on the present more than ever before.
So here's some of the core,
uh,
postulates of the SST theory.
First,
the perception of time is going to influence our social and emotional goals.
Second,
our goals are going to influence then how we process information.
And third,
then pursuing emotional goals is going to be good for our emotion regulation.
So then how do emotions exactly change as we grow older?
So here we're going to turn to the empirical evidence on emotion and aging to
really answer this question of how and when do our emotions change as we grow
older.
So let's turn to emotion and aging.
Um,
this has been a really interesting topic and gain a lot of widespread media
attention.
So we see articles like this in time saying with age comes happiness,
right?
Um,
so they say wisdom may come with age,
but does happiness follow suit?
Some studies show that the elderly may be prone to depression and loneliness,
which can lead to higher rates of unhappiness,
not a surprise,
but dot,
dot,
dot.
Increasing.
More and more studies suggest that happiness may actually rise after middle age.
So where is the data for this?
Um,
well,
you can see additional outlets like the New York tends also talking about this
really exciting empirical evidence that Happiness Matt actually come with age.
And finally,
uh,
in the BBC there's headlines such as people get happier as they age.
Most people get happier as they grow.
Older studies on people aged up to their mid ninety's suggests.
So what is going on here?
In what ways and why can becoming older actually make us happier?
So broken this up into three categories that can help answer this question of
how becoming older may actually lead to increase happiness.
And the three domains here are as follows,
we'll go through them each.
So we see an increased experience of positive emotion,
increased attention to positive stimuli and increase the ability to actually
regulate our emotions.
Right?
So this is work that's been largely carried out by a doctor Laura Carstensen,
um,
where she's looked at volunteers ranging in age from 18 all the way into the mid
nineties to come and take part in various experiments as well as keep diaries of
their emotional states.
So let's go through first starting with this empirical evidence that actually
suggest that as we get older we experience more positive emotions rather than
less.
And here's one of the landmark studies that was done by car since an in
colleagues titled Emotional Experience Improves With Age evidence based on over
10 years of experience sampling.
So here they use an experienced sampling procedure,
measuring emotions five times a day for approximately one week and they repeated
it again five years and 10 years later.
So let me show you what this looked like.
So participants came into the lab,
they complete an experience sampling protocol where they measured emotion in
their daily lives five times a day.
They reported both positive and negative emotion for over the course of a week.
Then they were brought back five years later and again,
10 years later and hear.
What they did is they conducted really sophisticated statistical analyses,
both cross sectional as well as growth curve modeling,
which indicated that aging was associated with increased positive emotion
overall as well as that they found additionally greater emotional wellbeing.
So when people's everyday life emotion experience actually does seem to increase
with age,
both cross-sectionally comparing adults of different ages as well as following
individuals across their own lifespan five and 10 years later.
And here you can see a graph from her paper where she maps positive emotional
experience with increased numbers here reflect in greater positive emotional
experience.
And here's looking at age 20 all the way over,
down to 90 and as you can see here,
we see this increase rise and positive emotional experience across the lifespan.
Okay,
so we see increased experience of positive emotion.
What about the way people visually process are taken?
Emotional information from the world around them?
Do individuals who are older actually see the world through rosy colored
glasses?
Do they become another words older and Rosier?
So this is really interesting work that's looked at attentional biases.
And here if you see this graph here,
what you find is that when researchers,
researchers have compared younger to older adults,
they find an increased attentional bias.
So people's sort of visual attention is more drawn towards,
are captured by positive faces compared to negative faces.
So you see this effect pronounced an older adults and younger adults with the
positive face bias score significantly greater than the positive bias score and
yellow compared to younger adults.
So we also see that older adults actually attend to away from native faces as
well compared to younger adults.
So their attention is drawn towards positive stimuli and drawn away from
negative stimuli in older adults compared to younger adults.
We also see additional work by Derek,
exactly within colleagues where they've recently compared two main methods of
assessing how much people visually attend to and take in the world around them.
To answer the question is,
is there an age related positivity effect in visual attention?
So,
so including comparing what we refer to as eye tracking methodologies.
So these are technologies used to continuously monitor the point of gaze in
response to standard positive,
negative and neutral images as well as you can see here.
Dot Pro paradigms that allow enable researchers even more directly assess
potential biases and patterns of attentional distribution when they're
presented,
for example,
on a computer screen with competing emotional faces that maybe either positive
or negative.
And here indeed they find that there is suggestive results for what they've
called this positivity effect in older adults that is older adults actually
preferentially attend.
That is their eyes sort of orient towards positive visual information in the
world around them.
So in some ways it seems that adults who are older not only experience more
positive emotion,
but they actually do sort of see the world through more positive rosy colored
glasses.
So now we're going to look at the idea of emotion regulation.
Not only do older adults feel more positive,
they see the world in a more positive light,
but they actually have an increased ability to harness or regulate their
emotions.
So when we talked about adolescents having no breaks,
it seems as if older adults have supremely refined emotional breaks and having
an increased ability to actually harness and regulate their emotions.
So this is work done by James Gross,
Laura Carstensen,
Jeannie sign and other colleagues looking at emotion and aging.
And here,
despite popular stereotypes that older people become less emotional.
First there's little evidence of that.
And second,
gross and colleagues decided to systematically examine across several samples
from geographically and ethnically distinct backgrounds showing that compared to
the younger participants,
older participants report fewer negative emotional experiences and greater
emotional control.
So indeed we see that as adults age,
they exhibit greater emotional control.
And this has led,
um,
early and gross to develop a model what they,
that they've called the soccer model.
So it's the selected selection,
optimization and compensation with emotion regulation model.
So I want you to look at this graph carefully.
I'm going to walk you through it.
So they argue that older adults select and optimize emotion regulation processes
that take advantage of resource games and compensate for resorts losses.
Specifically we see in this figure that older adults receive more encouragement
from others to get involved in positive situations represented by a larger oval
size that you can see on the top right because they have a smaller but closer
social network.
So this represents what they would call a resource gain,
an older,
older age.
And since older adults may also have less cognitive control represented by a
smaller oval,
you would expect younger adults to use more cognitive reappraisal indicated by a
relatively larger oval on the bottom left hand corner,
um,
compared to older adults.
So this is a really interesting model that I highly encourage you to read more
about that suggest in what ways older adults are really able to become more
effective emotion regulators by really taking advantage of resource gains and
compensating for potential resource losses.
That is cognitive decline that we see,
you know,
decrease over age they make up for it by engaging in other kinds of situations
that really capitalize on their,
you know,
intimate and really selectively tuned social networks.
So in conclusion,
we've seen this evidence for what's called the positivity effect.
When we think of emotion and aging,
which is the,
the fact that as humans get older there is a relative preference for positive
over negative information.
So it's almost as if as we get older we sort of tune ourselves towards positive
information and sort of back away from negative emotional information.
And if you're interested in this,
I highly encourage you to watch this talk by Dr Laura Carstensen called older
people are happier.
She's a fantastic speaker and really reviews a lot of the evidence that we've
discussed today for just how we can sort of reapproach the end of life.
Not think of it as a time of existential crisis and health related difficulties
and frustration,
but actually as an opportunity to experience more positive emotion,
cherished times with other people who we intimately value and actually become
wiser and happier as a result.
So with that,
I'll turn to our takeaway questions.
The first question today,
ask,
what is the socioemotional selectivity theory and what are at central
postulates?
Second,
what is the supportive evidence that we discussed today indicating that we may
actually become happier as we grow older?
And finally,
how does emotion regulation change as we age or grow older?
Now I'll turn to our expert interview as part of our experts in emotion
interview series.
Okay.
I have the pleasure today of speaking with doctor Laura Carstensen on emotion
and aging.
Dr. Carson is a professor of psychology and the fairly Dixon junior professor in
public policy at Stanford University where she's also the founding director of
the Stanford Center on longevity,
which explores innovative ways to solve the problems of people over 50 and
improve the wellbeing of people across all ages.
She received her bs from the University of Rochester and phd in clinical
psychology from West Virginia University.
Dr. Carson is best known in academia for the socioemotional selectivity theory,
a lifespan theory of motivation and with her students and colleagues has
published well over 125 articles on lifespan development.
Okay.
Her research has been supported by the national institute on Aging for more than
20 years and in 2011 she authored along bright future happiness,
health and financial security in an age of increased longevity.
She's a fellow of the association for Psychological Science,
the American Psychological Association and the Gerontological Society of
America.
She has chaired two studies for the National Academy of Sciences resulting in
the aging mind,
and when I'm 64 she's a member of the Macarthur Foundation's research on an
aging society.
Not Surprising.
Dr Carson's and has won numerous awards,
including a Guggenheim Fellowship and the distinguished career award from the
Gerontological Society of America.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Laura Carstensen
on emotion and aging.